Narrator: As we entered in to World war I
the British already had a
presence in the Middle East.
Egypt was already a British protectorate
and it formalized this as we entered in to
World War I and they don't
get their independence
until 1922.
The British don't just hand it to them,
they fight for this, they have a revolt
against the British rule and they win,
so you have an independent Egypt in 1922.
The British also had
Kuwait as a protectorate
and this is from the
1800's and they don't get
their independence until 1961.
We also know that the British were eager
to get the help of the Arab's,
to essentially convince
the Arab's to revolt
against the Ottoman's so
that they could successfully
fight the Ottoman's on the
Sinai and Palestine fronts
and on the Mesopotamia front.
In particular, they tried
to convince this gentleman,
Hussein bin Ali, who at the time,
at the beginning of World War I
is the Sharif of Mecca.
In order to convince him
they made promises to him.
We have a whole video
on the McMahon-Hussein
correspondence.
They say look if you help
up us we will give you
and independent state,
an independent Arab state
that would include all of this territory
except for maybe, except
for maybe this region
right up here.
So, with those British
assurances he agrees
to commit his forces to
fight in the Arab revolt,
to rise up and to help the British.
From that point on in 1916 where you have
the Arab revolt, he declares himself as
the King of the Hejaz.
Just as a little bit
of a geography tangent
right over here, this is the Hejaz.
It's kind of the west coast of the Arabian
peninsula and it contains
the very influential towns
of Mecca and Medina.
You might say, well whatever
happened to the Hejaz?
Isn't all of this region
right now Saudi Arabia?
And you are correct.
What happened shortly after, so in 1916
he declares himself King of the Hejaz
but then you had another
group, the Saudi's
in the Nejd region, which is
this area right over here.
They are able to, in 1925, successfully,
successfully, successfully
conquer the Nejd
and you have Ibn Saud who declares himself
King of the Nejd and
Hejaz from 1926 to 1932.
He later merges them into Saudi Arabia
and he's the first King of Saudi Arabia
all the way until 1953.
That's how you get Saudi Arabia.
Now, let's continue, let's rewind back to
World War I.
You have the Arab revolt.
Hussein bin Ali declares himself the King
of the Hejaz.
Two of his sons are very
active in collaborating
with the British to fight
against the Ottoman's.
This right over here
is Faisal bin Hussein.
Bin Hussein literally
means son of Hussein.
This right over here is Abdullah.
By the end of the war,
and we covered this in the
Sinai, Palestine and
Mesopotamia Campaigns,
the combined British
and Arab forces are able
to move all the way into,
all the way into what
is now northern Syria.
They're all able to move into what is now
northern Iraq.
You can imagine at this
point, the Arab's are eager
in a post world environment
to have their state.
The reason why they're
a little bit unceratin
about their future is based
on what some of the things
that came out during the war.
We now know that while
the British were trying to
convince Hussein bin Ali to
get his forces to rise up
against the Ottoman's
they were dealing with
the French in the secret
Sykes-Picot Agreement
to essentially carve
up this whole territory
between the British and the French.
They really weren't talking
about independent states
for the Arab's.
A few years later in 1917,
this was still during the war,
while the war was happening,
you have the Balfour Declaration,
which declared the
British intent to create
a homeland for the Jewish people.
Then a month later, really
the end of that month,
November 1917, the Russian's make the
Sykes-Picot Agreement public,
so all of these things
made the Arab's very uneasy.
They got assurances from the British that
oh that wasn't that
serious of an agreement,
just keep fighting with us.
So, at the end of the war
they were eager to get,
what they thought, was their just claim.
So you have Faisal bin
Hussein, he attends the
Paris Peace Conference in 1919.
(writing) So in 1919 you have the Paris,
Paris Peace Conference
and just to be clear
at that point in time it
wasn't obvious that you
necessarily had to have
this, what we now have,
is this conflict between
what is now Israel
and the Arab people.
Faisal bin Hussein was
actually eager to kind of
reach out to the World
Zionist Organization,
to the Zionist movement to
hopefully get their help
in establishing an independent Arab state.
He didn't think that they would,
that it would establish an
independent Jewish state,
but he said hey look if they
can have a homeland here
but in order to get that homeland,
they're willing to support
me for an independent
Arab state then I might
kind of send out an
olive branch to them.
This right over here is a
quote by Faisal bin Hussein.
This is while he was trying to get support
for an independent Arab
state, one that he would
argue, was promised to him by
the McMahon Correspondences
with his father.
So, this is Faisal.
"We Arabs, look with the deepest sympathy
"on the Zionist movement.
"Our deputation here in Paris is fully
"acquainted with the
proposal submitted yesterday
"by the Zionist Organization
to the Peace Conference
"and we regard them as
moderate and proper.
"We will do our best, in
so far as we are concerned
"to help them through,
we will wish the Jews
"a most hearty welcome home.
"I look forward, and my
people with me look forward
"to a future in which we
will help you and you will
"help us so that the
countries in which we are
"mutually interested may
once again take their
"places in the community
of the civilized peoples
"of the world."
But he did throw in this
caveat, he was doing this
because he wanted their support for
an independent state and
he did throw in the caveat,
look this only applies,
I'm only supportive,
essentially, of the Balfour Declaration
if we get our independent state.
He really wanted ... he
really wanted an independent,
(writing) independent state.
He explicitly said, hey
look if we don't get
an independent state all
the stuff I said here,
doesn't really apply.
So you end of with the
Treaty of Sev in 1920.
It turns out that the
Sykes-Picot Agreement
held a lot more weight than the assurances
between McMahon and Hussein because in the
Treaty of Sev, this area
was divided, essentially,
according to the Sykes-Picot Agreement.
Up here, this whole region
was given to France,
they called it a mandate,
which is essentially
it was allowed to be occupied by France
but they called it a mandate.
The allies wanted it
to be called a mandate
so it didn't look like
France was getting something.
A mandate is kind of,
hey you have to come help
these people to transition
them to establish a state,
to help them transition
institutions so eventually they
can get independence.
The allies wanted it to appear that,
look central powers, look Ottoman's,
you're not giving us something,
you're not giving us this territory,
you're giving us a responsibility.
Needless to say, they were eager to occupy
this territory, so eager
that when Faisal bin Hussein,
in 1920, declared himself King of Syria,
they booted him out.
He was in really no power
to contest that booting out.
This area right over
here, this was pretty much
in line with the Sykes-Picot Agreement,
became a British, this
whole area right over here
became a British mandate.
Now, in what is now Iraq,
you essentially have
an uprising in 1920,
they don't appreciate,
they thought that they
were going to become
independent now.
They were free of the Ottoman's,
but now all of a sudden the British come
and say that they are in charge.
So you have this revolt
against the British in 1920.
The British start to realize, gee this is
kind of expensive trying
to keep control of this
maybe we should install someone,
and we'll still kind of
keep this as a protectorate
as a mandated territory, but why don't we
install someone, an
Arab leader, as the King
of this region.
So, the install Faisal bin Hussein
as a King of Iraq.
He is a King of Iraq,
essentially under protection,
or under influence of the British
from 1921 until 1933 and
that's when they finally
get independence of the British, in 1932.
When they get booted out of Syria,
his brother Abdullah,
son of Hussein bin Ali,
he's allowed to become
King of trans Jordan.
They later get independence in 1946
after World War II at
which point he becomes
the King of Jordan.
Syria and Lebanon, they
don't get independence
until during or after World War II.
Lebanon gets independence in 1943,
Syria gets independence
from the French in 1946.
And we know that the mandate of Palestine,
which the British kept,
this would continue
to be a sore point through World War II
and then with the
establishment of the state
of Israel shortly afterwards,
it becomes a very,
I guess we could say, hot
point in international affairs.